do something that you're passionate
about it's a tough Journey it's a long
journey so if you enter into it make
sure that you're passionate about it and
it's not just you know a cool thing that
someone told you about this is one thing
uh second
um surround yourself with people uh that
you trust and people that are positive
it's a tough Journey again so you need
positivity along the journey and maybe
the third part is don't get excited or
depressed too often about you know the
highest it's a roller coaster
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctec
hello and welcome to another episode of
20 minute leaders today I'm with guy
begurano co-founder and CEO of safe
breach safe breach is an offensive cyber
security company for the service of
Defense it is the world's most widely
used breach and attack simulation
platform and the Pioneer to set this
category in Gartner the company's
patented platform provides a near
real-time Hacker's view of an
Enterprise's security posture to
proactively predict attacks validate
security controls and improve security
operations center analyst response
capabilities guy founded safe Bridge
together with itsy kotler in 2014 prior
to funding the company beijorano has
worked as a CSO in life person and
kotler has spent time in 8200 unit and
the IDF as a hacker the companies in
Rapid growth and have raised 106 million
dollars to date it has tripled its
employee's number in the past nine
months currently with over 150 and they
have over 100 major customers
foreign
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for being here with me how are
you
I'm doing great Michael thanks for
having me
thank you so much for being here guy and
today you're the co-founder and CEO of
safe breach an amazing amazing company
we just discussed how I have a quite a
few friends who've walked through your
corridors
um looking at and breaching attack
simulations cyber security and obviously
a world that that is dear to my heart
and then I've accepted to unfold a
little bit with you over these 20
minutes but your journey doesn't start
here you've acted as a
um executive in the Securities field in
life person and mass Technologies and so
looking you know quite a bit of Journey
inside I'd love to start their guy you
know
come a little bit about your own
interaction with the security world
where does this all start from for you
what draws you into it
well actually what draws brought me into
the security space uh it was by accident
um when a second I mean literally by
accident I had an accident
that kind of took my curse course off uh
going to the pilots course in the
Israeli Air Force onto security uh so I
had no idea what I'm getting into that
was back in the 90s a long time ago and
I fell in love in this
um you know
um
base that was evolving back then in the
days and did a lot of uh amazing stuff
in the during the service time with a
lot of security around the avionics and
weapon systems and things like that and
build the red team in the air force uh
which was very contribution to the the
um back in the days uh the perception of
offensive defense and really tried to
leverage a new perception
um to the benefit of the Defenders and
through that growing tool as you said
you know a few season roles
and build safe rage started about eight
years ago
Martin Luther Nacho
so
truck driving on your positions is
see-through and then a few organizations
multinational or Global organizations
what were some of the key insights that
that you had with you as you were going
through those Journeys that led to the
formation of safe breach
well I'll say a few things uh one the
Cecil's role um is very challenging in a
sense that uh I stole my my role as an
executive
um as the person that needs to translate
a lot of technical data into business
data and and business realization of
what is our real risk to the company
what are the drivers that can help me to
support the business uh security wise
and there was nothing in the market that
really you know helped me to do that so
I realized that back in the days I was a
live person and and it's a cloud
platform a lot of the challenges were to
convince the large Enterprises to move
their uh critical data uh onto our
platform and we did that through proving
our worth and security and the way you
do that is actually you know showing
behind the curtains or under the wood
and really went from staring to what you
have and let them challenge you uh so I
try to take that to the next level and I
think all those uh proactive programs
that will challenge our security and our
customers so we would you know won't
have to face it first time in production
um and then I I literally hit a glass
ceiling because there was nothing in the
market that could help me do that we
tried to build some on-grown solutions
but none of them was you know scalable
enough to build a program around it and
I remember the the
um the feed actually got me going and
building something of my own I brought
him to you why they're hackers
um and after they showed me four ways to
hack into our system and get uh
confidential information I asked them
about uh is there a First scenario is
there a tense scenario or more and what
about the four that they just found or
they valid next week or next month and
they had no answer
so they said you know we need to retest
what we just did or maybe there is
another scenario we didn't think about
we need to keep on you know trying we
will probably find it
and one of them and realize what I'm
trying to do we he actually connected me
to my co-founder and that's how Savage
actually started
we're looking at at the world at that
moment okay eight years ago and we're
looking at this idea of of
um attack simulations you know a red
team trying to say okay we have you know
we we know what we know and we have
perhaps Solutions or you know defense
mechanisms for what we already know we
need to be worried of but there's this
whole world of unknown right this is
sort of the realization that you come to
there's this whole world of unknown and
there is this kill there's these people
who have the skill sets to come and
Challenge and test what I don't know and
try to figure that out
where is the world in position to this
for my some sort of a market education
perspective is this a trivial concept is
this a concept that you then have to
sort of explain and educate the market
but the good question so first of all I
would say that
um it's not that we know what we know
it's we think we know what we know what
we know there's a lot of unknowns in
what is possibly trivial so if you take
for example any you know average
organization across organization today
anyway you will ask yes this is so are
the susceptible to an attack that
happened a few months back
if they're not using anything like the
average there's no way for them to know
but you'll be guessing kind of are
hoping so a hope strategy uh what we've
introduced to the market is the first
time the ability to really test yourself
against something that might happen and
using that data to understand how good
are your defenses I think the market
today really changed and shifted the uh
for where it was eight years ago and you
can see the latest Announcement by the
U.S government and by sisa that actually
uh Embraces continuous validation
testing as part of the standard for
Enterprise to really uh um increase
their security efficacy and reduce risk
and and these are Concepts that we've
established two years back and now
becoming more and more acceptable by the
industry
right so take me back eight years you're
forming this company you understand the
the vacuum the garden they exists you
understand that you have a great
co-founder you understand there is these
people that you can bring on board how
do you how do you build this this
monster how do you build this company
from the ground up
um I can tell you that we had the plan
in advance but uh that wouldn't be true
uh what we did we actually partnered
with a great VC so we started by Sequoia
um and through that we started to really
listen to the market and the market
needs so we started to work with the EU
security through a set a Bunches of
Enterprise organizations and we started
to work with them and to realize what's
working what's not
um beside the Enterprise Market is our
main focus and through literally to you
know the need of their csos and we
started to build a platform uh at the
beginning we focused only on the red
side
and that will realize that the blue side
is is very important as well because
it's not just showing you an
organization that they have gaps but
it's actually to help them to mitigate
the gaps uh will be cool right
so we're really shifted through through
the years
um and that's how you know it all
started and grew and obviously today
um you know we're
150 people across the globe we started
with the US operations but we have an
office in in the UK in Singapore
obviously the tech side in Israel
right of course if you're taking you
know Enterprise customers or any you
know company that this would be relevant
for just walk me through sort of the the
traditional use case of what what an
engagement with State Bridge would look
like and I'm sure this was something
that you know a lot of people that
aren't coming from the cyber security
scene our characters okay are there
literally people with hoodies sitting
around trying to hack into their
companies and and how does this whole
thing happen you know let's let's ground
this a little bit as to what actually
takes place from a company perspective
sounds good so basically we've uh we've
built a software solution
um uh it's fully automated and the idea
is that we're bringing the attack to an
organization in a controlled way so they
they're using our software to really uh
play War Games within their
infrastructure whether it will be an
on-prem Cloud whatever it is
until doing that we have we have a few
patents that we've invented that
actually enables us to do that in a very
fast and easy way and also in a very
safe safe manner so it doesn't impact
your production so you can actually run
real uh executables in your production
in a controlled way and see and then
listen to your security controls we do
that through apis and we listen to the
controls and and try to understand what
did they see what did they try to do
either they try to prevent our action uh
did they detect it did they send the
right alert to your sock and we then
compile all these into one image that
that Sissel gets that shows them what
their level of prevention and detection
and how much of everything week through
Adam they've missed
uh we take all this information and look
it back to the security controls so they
can you know modify their configuration
based on our attacks and make sure that
next line someone launches a similar
attack they will either prevent it or
detect it and actually do what their
security controls in Canada do
um so how do they see safe bridge if
you're looking at the systems of those
organization then they're looking at
sort of the landscape of vendors that
they're working with to try and mitigate
you know the world around them that's
trying to defend their ability to
operate safely in their Core Business
and and what in what way do you imagine
that your customers are positioning safe
bridge in their head or in their in
their sort of cognitive landscape
so we're literally kind of uh the layer
of Truth
right the actual what will happen if
they will do anything yes what what
their cost of avoidance uh right we're
looking at the same two different angles
one would be the security vendor
um and the control validation so an
average you know people talk about
average of I know 70 to 100 tools used
by the Enterprise today security tools a
lot of complexity is just enormous uh
they have no real way to really cope
with the level of that complexity
um sure and what we do in a simple
manner we show them what's the efficacy
of all these controls not just you know
against one another but you know let's
say that you have 50 different instances
of your you know the best the best
next-gen firewall in the industry uh you
expect that you know all the safety to
act the same because they're machines
right uh well guess what usually it's
not the case so launching the attack
against all of them will show you
exactly where they're falling short
sometimes it's a configuration matter
actually most of the time and sometimes
it's you know a blank spot that vendors
specific vendor ads and then our
customers can go to the vendor and
actually ask for a solution
um the other side is coming from the
threat landscape so what we've compiled
into our into our software uh all the
threat actors you want to test yourself
against any ransomware permutation you
want to test yourself against an APK 29
the cool zipper you know from Russia you
want to test it against the Iranian the
the Chinese whatever threat actor out
there we will provide that within the
platform and they can actually know
exactly how you will cope with them uh
when the time comes it's a great tool
for cecils then take this information
into the boardroom and actually talk
about real risk so what's up what's the
level of risk that we will impose you
know a guess of ransomware attack based
on our controls
so it sounds like
in the first sentence is it started
explaining what the which is done now
started this layer of Truth okay let's
say when hits the fan right what
actually is going to happen what is the
risk that we are positioning ourselves
against and then being able to test that
in a very real way right I mean that's
what the whole point is let's actually
simulate it in a in a very real
environment because this is how it would
actually turn out if this was the case
right correct you how where is the guy
in all this if you're looking sort of at
you know your own journey and you
mentioned how it all started as an
accident and then a variety of sister
roles and now an entrepreneur and and
CEO of and thought leader in the space
where do you see yourself in this whole
construction as a part of your own
personal system
uh I love the question so first of all
I'm enjoying myself because it's uh it's
all new
its building is uh it's literally
trailblazing it's uh going against the
conception of what I believe is the
broken industry very styling industry
and trying to and
I know um I can you know see you know
today from another eight years
succeeding to change the mindset of the
industry
um so guys enjoying that part I really
love the fact that we managed to make a
change into something that was certainly
for me at pain point so
um and we've managed to build a solution
that provides an answer a stable answer
I'd say
um so I'm enjoying the that moment and
I'm thinking about okay I can take that
to the next level
so
well it's it's you look at your own uh
and your own trajectory is to the world
that you're in you see yourself staying
in security you know as sort of a life
mission is this something that that you
thought it was something that I truly
enjoy and passionate about or are there
different things that that you find that
excite you in this world
well determinational first of all
security has definitely that you know
security for my entire adult life and I
definitely see that as a mission uh
personally for me because I don't
believe in you know if something is not
working and if it's broken and the fact
that people for years uh have accepted
that
uh that really you know kind of bugs me
and I that that would that fun that's
why I provide my real Drive besides that
I super enjoy you know everything around
building a company interaction with you
know uh employees inspiring uh you know
working with customers learning uh even
saving that's part of that so what I was
curious about guy if you're looking back
now eight years as to sort of this
journey that you've been on in the
entrepreneurial Journey
you're pretty even security inside for a
second were there things that you're now
looking back and saying wow this is not
something I expected this is not how I
thought it was going to feel like or be
or these are I didn't expect these to be
the challenges that I would be facing as
an entrepreneur and as an executive do
you have any of those examples in mind
of basically looking back are wow this
is something that I didn't expect
oh yeah I'd say plenty
um I think the the journey is nothing
that you know um it turned to be nothing
that I thought of uh in terms of
expecting you know the the highs and
lows
um and I'll say daily examples of uh
activities I didn't think that I would
go through
um and I find you know today in a
retrospective I find that something I
really enjoy so building a company has a
lot of aspects that doesn't relate you
know to security or security Market that
you need to actually uh learn and grow
into and I think that my personal growth
also is something that I really enjoy in
terms of you know being a CEO first time
CEO
um and learning a lot through that
Journey
amazing and so if you're looking now to
let's say we're returning to you know
college students some of them are
excited to start their own charity and
become first-time CEOs if you happen to
sell your sort of your ethos now into
what is something conceptually that you
would advise them to consider or to
think about as they're approaching this
journey what what is what would you
advise to really keep in mind every day
uh so by the way first of all I do that
today so part of giving back I work with
young entrepreneurs
um in multiple programs and share my you
know my scars
um and and my experience and let them
you know at least speak from that the
few things that I would recommend any
entrepreneur would be first of all
do something that you're passionate
about it's a tough Journey it's a long
journey so if you enter into it make
sure that you're passionate about it and
it's not just you know a cool thing that
someone told you about this is one thing
uh second
um surround yourself with people uh that
you trust and people that are positive
it's a tough Journey again so you need
positivity along the journey and maybe
the third part is don't get excited or
depressed too often about you know the
highest it's a roller coaster some days
you wake up say like
what the hell have I done and suddenly
in other days you think you you're on
top of the world you know uh take it
down a notch and in both ways
I love it guy I really want to thank you
uh as part two friends one for joining
this show and for spending this time
with me but also for for the amazing
work that you're doing and with Steve
bridge should say it's really um
inspiring for others on the side and I'm
putting myself in that category to see
this journey of yours and and what
you've built and and the concept behind
it and the the Excellency that that Save
which represents and and I personally
know this just from from Friends who've
walked to your own corridors you know
this culture of Excellency and where
you're how you're pushing the envelope
and so I I really want to thank you for
for coming here and for spending this
time and stay safe and stay healthy
thank you guys
fun podcast thank you
foreign